here are five hidden signs that your
body is inflamed and you need to act now
I'm a dietitian and I see this all the
time do you experience bloating
headaches mood swings fatigue or brain
fog If you experience three or more of
these very debilitating symptoms believe
it or not you're probably totally normal
yay
yay influencers
from the stop these pretty vague
symptoms to prove that there's something
wrong with you and then of course you
need some kind of supplement that
they're selling to try to fix it the
reality is sometimes you feel bloated
because you ate a lot of cabbage course
these symptoms can be linked to
something more Sinister so I'm not
dismissing that there are clinical
conditions that can be linked to these
experiences but for the most part people
on this app don't have a damn clue about
your unique medical history and listing
off a bunch of random symptoms to try to
sell you a program or a product is
unprofessional and predatory if it's
even coming from a professional at the
end of the day if it seems
oversimplified without context or vague
it's probably BS